no TV in that case Sascha Canopus in
Europe's icebox in our words our Sweden
where it's minus 25 degrees Celsius he's
here to test the 221 kilowatt go far he
doesn't expect to get anywhere near the
rate at seven point one litre fuel
consumption though he's here to practice
driving on ice but before her car tester
can get out on the frozen lake he has to
take a special driving safety course the
volkswagen driving experience training
course runs the world's northernmost
driving safety centre here depending on
the weather
arctic automotive adventures can come
here to get experience driving on ice
and snow between February and late March
driving instructor Benjamin loiter has
the participants turned Donuts so they
can learn to control a drifting car a
situation they don't encounter every day
out driving in the city for the day's
first exercise the participants learn
about drifting and their car is no less
than the most powerful golf that VW has
to offer and that's the car we're going
to take a closer look at
any driver who's experienced the Gulf
are in action on snow and ice will
hardly want to go back to dry roads
turning Donuts is more fun this is the
sportiest series produce golf and it
looks it it proudly wears the are in its
grille and on the rear so other drivers
can see just what drifted past them the
participants here quickly realize it
takes lots of practice to learn to
control a drift meanwhile we can take a
peek at the Gulf ARS interior typically
for the golf the cockpit is uncluttered
no unnecessary gadgetry to distract the
driver from what's important the view of
the road the seats provide lateral
support the better for the driver to
feel the road underneath the speedometer
goes all the way up to 320 km/h but the
car is electronically limited to 250
back on the ice this golf's been used as
a dogsled without the docks
the front air intakes have to be cleared
of snow to keep the two-liter turbo
four-cylinder engine from overheating in
spite of the cold benjamine moisture
says everyone should take some driving
training once a year the instructors
themselves take training every year he
says it's important to get a fine sense
of how the car turns on the ice that's
what drivers can learn meant the
volkswagen driving experience and some
learn quickly others learn not as
quickly here you want to go look look to
me looked at me look to me here you want
to go don't look at the snow wall when
you when you feel that you're going too
fast
never look to the snow wall always look
in that direction where you want to go
the 380 Newton meters of torque have to
be kept on a tight leash the standard
all-wheel drive grips the road and helps
to push the goal far from 0 to 100 and
5.1 seconds Sacha Kopp would be happy
just to begin to learn to drive like
this Benjamin Royston tries to give his
students a good start in just four days
depending on the driving experience they
bring to the training course
now it's time for Sasha to take the
wheel
Benjamin loiter is highly impressed with
the enhanced engine performance with its
300 horsepower pushing all four wheels
he says the car is a success all around
he especially likes the new holodecks
drive coupling saying it responds much
faster than the one in the sixth
generation go far he says the car is
easy and safe to drive even for the
average Joe it's easy to control in
extreme situations driving the go far on
ice is almost addicting he can hardly
let go of it
after his drifting experience sasha is
all but speechless but it's an
experience that costs around two
thousand nine hundred euros altogether
the driving experience here in average
our sweden is definitely not cheap but
sasha is seldom had as much fun in four
days especially not in a Golf R